MAINTAIN CONTROL.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME REACTION TO THE
EXPANDED PROBE OF THE PRESIDENT,
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME IS HERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS GENERICALLY ABOUT
THIS LAUNCH, THE FLURRY OF
DOCUMENTS REQUEST.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY ACTION
THAT THIS IS COMING AT A TIME
WHEN THERE'S WIDESPREAD
EXPECTATION THAT MUELLER HAS
ABOUT FINISHED HIS JOB.
THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE MANY
PEOPLE KNOW WHO ANY LONGER THINK
HE WILL COME UP WITH SOME KIND
OF CONSPIRACY THEORY RELATED TO
COLLUSION BY THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
SIMILARLY, THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOME DOUBT THAT HE WILL MAKE ANY
KIND OF ALLEGATIONS TO THE
EFFECT THAT PRESIDENT HIMSELF
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
ALTHOUGH YOU HEARD JERROLD
NADLER SAY HE THINKS THERE'S
LOTS OF EVIDENCE OF THAT OR HE
THINKS IT'S CLEAR THAT'S TRUE.
IF HE DID, WHY NOT MOVE TO
IMPEACHMENT?
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
THE SEARCH IS ON FOR SOMETHING
ELSE.
THEY MAY TRY TO FIGURE OUT AND
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CHARGE
BUT IT APPEARS THEY ARE MOVING
AWAY FROM COLLUSION.
I THINK, BRET, THAT THERE IS
SOME THOUGHT THAT MUELLER,
BECAUSE HE'S NOT GOING TO INDICT
ON COLLUSION OR CONSPIRACY TO
COLLABORATE OR WHATEVER, MAY SAY
NOTHING ABOUT THAT AT ALL.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
I THINK HE IS BOUND TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT OR AT LEAST
REPORT SOMETHING ABOUT IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECAUSE THAT
WAS PART OF HIS ORIGINAL CHARGE.
MUELLER'S ORIGINAL CHARGE WAS TO
INVESTIGATE THAT AMONG SEVERAL
OTHER THINGS.
I THINK YOU WILL REACH
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT THAT AND THEY
WILL BECOME PUBLIC.
IF THEY DON'T SAY ANYTHING
INCRIMINATING ON THAT SCORE, I
WONDER HOW MUCH WIND WILL REMAIN
IN THE SALES OF THAT CHARGE AND
SOME OTHERS.
>> Bret: IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW AND THE PROCESS GOES
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WE DON'T
KNOW.
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK LOOKING AT SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE
FINANCING IN THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
IS YOUR SENSE THAT THIS IS KIND
OF THE DEMOCRATS LOOKING FOR
ANOTHER ACE IN THE HOLE?
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE TO ME.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME WE HAVE
BEEN BURIED UNDER THESE
ALLEGATIONS AND ALL THE
SPECULATION THAT TRUMP WAS
GREATLY AIDED BY THE RUSSIANS IN
A GRAND CONSPIRACY TO THROW THE
ELECTION.
IF THAT DOESN'T PAN OUT, THE
PUBLIC HAS HEARD ALL OF THIS
TOO.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD QUESTION HOW
WELL THE PUBLIC WILL RECEIVE A
LOT OF CONTINUING INVESTIGATIONS
AND OTHER MATTERS.
IT'S CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
CAN COME UP WITH CRIMINAL
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE WAY HE
CONDUCTED HIS BUSINESS BUT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT POLICY DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR INDICTMENT FOR
THAT WHILE THE PRESIDENT IS IN
OFFICE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME EITHER THAT
AND IMPEACHMENT WOULD MAKE ANY
SENSE BECAUSE IMPEACHMENT I
THINK IS CLEARLY INTENDED FOR
THINGS DONE BY A PRESIDENT WHILE
HE IS IN OFFICE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE -- HE'S
GOING TO BE UNDER A TON OF
DOCUMENT REQUESTS AND CONTINUING
HEARINGS AND INVESTIGATIONS AND
SOUND AND FURY ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
HOW FAR IT WILL GO IF MUELLER
DOESN'T COME UP WITH SOMETHING
BIG, IS A GOOD QUESTION.
>> Bret: THERE IS POLITICALLY
A RISK-REWARD MOMENT FOR
DEMOCRATS.
AS YOU POINT OUT, WE ARE HEADING
INTO THE 2020 CYCLE.
ALREADY CANDIDATES ON THE TRAIL.
IF THE PRESIDENT WERE TO LOSE
THE ELECTION, THAT'S HOW HE
WOULD GET KICKED OUT OF OFFICE.
WE ALWAYS SEEM LIKE WE ARE ONE
ELECTION AWAY FROM SOLVING THE
BIG THING.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO MAKE A
CALCULATION, WHETHER IT'S ALL
INVESTIGATIONS OR IT'S ACTUALLY
LEGISLATION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH OXYGEN IN
THE ATMOSPHERE AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT IN POLITICS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TO TE
SUCKING IT ALL UP WITH AN
ENDLESS ROUNDS OF INVESTIGATIONS
ON THESE CIRCUS-LIKE HEARINGS
LIKE THE ONE LAST WEEK.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME THEY CAN
BUILD A CASE THAT THEY WILL NEED
TO BUILD TO TRY TO LEGISLATE OR
TO BE NOTICED LEGISLATING.
IN ALL THE REPORTING IS GOING TO
BE ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
MOST OF IT.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME KIND OF
CALCULATION AS TO WHAT IS BETTER
POLITICALLY?
TO INVESTIGATE OR ATTEMPT TO
LEGISLATE.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T PASS THINGS
AND GET THEM SIGNED, IF THEY
PASS A LOT OF BILLS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO VETO OR GET
BLOCKED IN THE SENATE, THOSE
BECOME ISSUES DEMOCRATS CAN RUN
ON AS A WAY TO GET THEIR
CANDIDATES AND THEIR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE ELECTED